in the lobby of the headquarters of
Ramsey solutions Damon and Chantelle or
with us hey guys how are you
great how are you hi welcome welcome
party all live Ambler Pennsylvania
outside of Philadelphia love it well
welcome to Nashville and how much debt
have you paid off one hundred and sixty
thousand dollars oh that's no small
number how long did that take thirty
eight months you've been kicking it and
your range of income was 150 thousand of
the two hundred twenty thousand Bing
Bing man knocking it down what are y'all
doing for a living
commercial real estate attorney ah okay
I'm in the house counsel for a
pharmaceutical company two attorneys two
lawyers well done all right and the real
estate business has gotten better yes
there's some title policies being
written somewhere like it very well done
you guys congratulations so what kind of
debt was the 160 who's mostly law school
and then the ten thousand left over was
our second mortgage okay cool so how
long y'all been married it'll be 11
years and November how long you been out
of law school since 2005 okay so three
years ago though 38 months ago something
happened what happened we had our second
out of three children and just got sick
of living paycheck to paycheck and not
making good money and not feeling like
we were a couple of broke lawyers yeah
pretty much
that's kind of sad do we want to be sad
anymore so what did you do uh the budget
is basically the biggest thing that
changed we were trying to put money away
but didn't have the ghazal intensity
they talked about the baby steps and so
we started a budget and I think that's
where it made all the difference and and
how did you did you should gizelle
intensity did you go through Financial
Peace University we actually started
listening to your podcast first okay and
then read the book and then went to
financial peace that's what a lot of
people do
yeah we started that but as Damon says
what's your phrase we weren't spenders
we were we were wasters yeah yeah yeah
we had no idea where the money was going
it was just just gone it's just going
yeah so and a lot of it I mean a lot of
money yes just gone getting rid of the
credit cards was the biggest thing
because that it's such an easy spend
that we didn't realize how much we were
spending on credit cards I mean wasn't
the debt but it just saved a lot of
money once we got rid of those and I
think it I think it's worth saying out
loud obviously your two lawyers so
you're not stupid people I mean you know
you're not I mean but that's just a
normal thing that's a normal behavior
issue that a lot of people face and you
guys just woke up and said alright
enough already
so did it start out intense or did you
kind of ramp up as you went along and
get more intense
it started out intense I think the you
know knocking each loan off fast you
know fast was helpful it was really hard
at the end when we had his last big loan
it took a whole year to to knock out oh
yeah and so just keeping up the momentum
and keeping up the you know pace of
seeing the end goal it was hard it was
really hard but we did it and we thought
what can we do after we're done here to
celebrate so what did what was the thing
that you cut out that was the hardest to
cut out mm-hmm no vacations that has
been the worst part no vacations and now
you get to enjoy Nashville which is a
cool town for the weekend beautiful fun
cool good for you
you bring the kids with you did and
their ages and names are what Joshua is
six Laura is three and Samuel will be
two in two weeks
oh wow okay we are so have they been
practicing in there debt-free screams
yes hromas death in the car all the way
down all the way down
all right well we've got a copy of Chris
Hogan's retire inspired but number one
bestseller to help you out move good at
to the next chapter a building wealth
and increasing your generosity factor
and all that kind of stuff it's an
incredible book you'll enjoy it thank
you and I'm very proud of y'all
congratulations
how does it feel to not have any law
school debt it's all gone
amazing feels great yeah gotta feel like
a hundred pounds off your shoulder yeah
I mean hundred and sixty panels and
dollars is pretty incredible thank you
well well done you guys well done
alright it's Damon and Chantal Joshua
Cora Samuel $160,000 paid off in 38
months making 150 to 220 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream 3 2 1
well done well done you guys man that is
kickin man that is kickin that is
awesomeness right there hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show